روسيا تمنع موظفيها من استخدام ايفون
والسعوديه نحو الفضاء خلال اشهر وتشير
الشرطه بنا الشالين اون لاين يثير جدلا في
السودان اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
مقال على صحيفه
الروسيه نشرت مقالا عنوانه اتصالات غير
مرغوب فيها الطلب من المسؤولين التخلص من
هواتف ايفون الامريكيه الصحيفه تقول نقلا
عن مصادر في الرئاسه لم تسميها ان مهلنا
مهله منحت لمسؤولين في الاداره الروسيه
حتى الاول من ابريل للتخلص من هواتفهم
المحموله ايفون والسبب هو مخاوف امنيه من
اختراق وكاله الاستخبارات الغربيه لهذه
الاجهزه وتقول الصحيفه ان القرار اتخذ
خلال ندوه للكرامل شارك فيها مسؤولون
ضالعون في السياسه الداخليه وصرح احدهم
نصا انتهى الامر بالنسبه لهواتف ايفون
ارموها بعيدا او اعطوها لاطفالكم على
الجميع تغيير هواتفهم في مارس وقيل ايضا
انه ممكن ان تقوم الاداره الرئاسيه بشراء
هواتف امنه جديده لموظفيها لتسهيل التخلي
عن التك الامريكيه ايفون كونها اكثر عرضه
للقرصنه وللتجسس من قبل الخبراء الغربيين
واقترح حضور في الاجتماع وفق الصحيفه ان
يمنح للمسؤولين هؤلاء هواتف تعمل بنظام
تشغيل اورورا الروسي او اندرويد الصيني
المتحدث باسم الكرملين سئل عن الموضوع
وقال ان هذه التقارير لا يمكن تاكيدها في
الوقت الراهن لكن صرح انه بكل الاحوال لا
يجب استخدام الهواتف الذكيه للاغراض
الرسميه يذكر ان الرئيس الروسيلاديمير
بوتين صرح سابقا انه لا يمكن لا يملك
هاتفا ذكيا والمتحدث باسمه قال ان الرئيس
يستخدم الدم الانترنت من وقت لاخر فقط
السؤال الان يا تمحور حول التقارير عن منع
الكرام المسؤولين من استخدام ايفون لمخاوف
من تجسس لاي درجه المخاوف في مكانها وهل
فعلا للمخابرات الغربيه القدره على التجسس
عبر هواتف من نوع معين دون ان غيرها او
ربما هذه محاوله من روسيا للانتقام من
امريكا لاتهام موسكو بالتدخل في
انتخاباتها في عام 2016 خاصه وان روسيا
على موعد مع انتخاباتها الرئاسيه في عام
ومن الرياض ينضم الينا صانع المحتوى
التقني فيصل السيف اهلا بك استاذ فيصل
نعرف ان عمليه التجسس غالبا ما تاتي عبر
الشبكات التواصل الاجتماعي او عبر الشبكات
الاتصالات او المنصات لكن نريد ان نستوضح
منك هل فعلا يتم التجسس عبر جهاز الايفون
نفسه
مساكم الله بالخير ولجميع الساده
المشاهدين الامر ممكن تقنيا بشكل جدا كبير
ولكن ما حيكون من خلال الشركه الام
الصانعه للهواتف او من خلال نفس النظام
ولكن حيكون من خلال اطراف ثالثه شركات
متخصصه في هذه الامور من طرف ثالث بعضها
متواجد في امريكا وبالتالي نعم الامر
تقنيا ممكن قابليه انه هذا الامر يتطبق او
ما يتطبق هذا يرجع الى قوه الاوامر اللي
تطلع من الجهات المعنيه للحصول على
المعلومات من هذه الاجهزه الموضوع نقدر
نقوله بكل شفافيه
تصير ليش لا
الخبر يقول انه ستستبدل نظام
روسي اخر ما هو هذا النظام وهل يمكن ان
يستخدم على ايفون نظام روسي
جميل الايفونات نفسها انه يكون عليها نظام
تشغيلي غير الاي او اس اللي هو حاليا
موجود عليها امر جدا مستبعد وما في قابليه
لهذا الامر كون انه الهاردوير العتاد
وايضا نفس البرامج التشغيليه
منسقه على بعض وبالتالي كيانهم موحد اما
لما نتكلم على انظمه روسيه بديله حاليا
موجوده على ارض الواقع بكثافه جدا عاليه
فهذا غير موجود ولكن ان تكلمنا على قابليه
الامن في امن المعلومات
جدي والامر واقعي بحيث انه اذا كانت روسيا
او نقدر نقول المسؤولين الروس من وجهه
نظري مهتمين لدرجه امان اعلى بان يكون
الانظمه والاجهزه اللي موجوده معاهم تابعي
لروسيا وهذا السيناريو ينطبق على اي مكان
واي دوله في العالم اذا انت قاعد تستخدم
تقنيه ليست محليه فبالتالي هذه التقنيه
وعدم تواجدها المحلي 100% يكون من خلالها
في نقدر نقول الا في مساله الامر
نعم يعني تعتبر ان الموضوع سياسي اكثر ما
هو تقني عن نفسي سياسي جدا لانه لو جينا
وشفنا اخر اربع سنوات من عام 2019 لما
بدات امريكا ضد هواوي الصينيه وبداوا
يتكلم عن موضوع البيانات ومن وقتها وكثير
من القيود تضع على شركات تقنيه صينيه
واللي احنا نعرف ونذكر نفسنا بانه
الاقتصاد الرقمي الامريكي احد اكبر موارد
الاقتصاد العالمي بالنسبه لامريكا
والايرادات منه تيجي كثير من شبكات
التواصل الاجتماعي من اجهزه الانظمه
الجوالات الاندرويد
فبالتالي لما يكون في منافسه على شبكات
التواصل وبعدين حرب نشوفها ضد هواوي خلتها
تطلع من رقم واحد في الماركت من المبيعات
تنزل الى الارقام العشره من ناحيه
المبيعات بدل ما كانت في الصداره وايضا
بعدها لما شفنا على تيك توك وشبكات تواصل
اجتماعي يكون في نفس النموذج بانه يتم
اتهامات بالاختراق لهذه الشبكات حق
التواصل الاجتماعي
نعرف ان الامر سياسي بشكل واقعي قبل ما
يكون تقني فهي المعامله بالمثل زي ما
امريكا قالت عن الصين انه عندكم تقنيات
منطقي
نعم لكن المخاوف شرعيه لانه حسب ما انت
تتكلم ان هناك ممكن ان يتم اختراق الاجهزه
الايفون لمسؤولين الروس وبالتالي هواجسهم
مشروع
[موسيقى]
اذا كان في هواتف نقدر نقول بانظمه
تشغيليه اقل وزنا واعتادا وكفاءه من
الاشياء اللي نشوفها في الهواتف الذكيه قد
ننتقل الى هواتف تعتمد على الشبكات فقط
لاتمام الاتصالات وليس بتصفح الانترنت
والبيانات وارسال واستقبال البيانات من
خلالها هذه احد الخيارات المطروحه
وبالتالي هذا الامر اصلا موجود في الشبكات
المحليه لكن يعني لن تكون هواتف ذكيه ومن
منا او من
يصبغني عن الهواتف الذكيه لهواتف اقل
بدرجه تقنيه اخف النقطه اللي انت ذكرتيها
جدا مهمه فبالتالي اذا الواحد قاعد يستخدم
الجوال لاسباب هذا لا يمنع انه يستخدم
جوال ثاني لاسباب اخرى موجوده عنده ونعرف
انه في جهات رسميه لما تجي انت تروح دوامك
في هذه الجهه الرسميه تتجنب ادخال
لابتوبات هذه تكلم حتى زمان الى الحين
بادخال لاب توب غير مصلح يكون موجود في
هذه المنظومه ونفس الامر ينطبق على
الاجهزه الجوال فانت عندك لابتوب ثاني
وعندك انظمه ثانيه ولكن ما تدخل معك
بالدوام الا انشاء محدده وما قالوا انه لا
يستخدم الافراد جبرا ما احد يستخدم اي
نظام الا الروسي
من الرياض كان معنا صانع المحتوى التقني
فيصل سيف شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
السعوديه تدخل مجال الابحاث الفضاء لخدمه
العلم والبشريه عنوان كشفت عنه الهيئه
السعوديه للفضاء وكتبت الهيئه عن المهام
والابحاث العلميه التي سيتم ارجائها خلال
رحله رائده ورائده فضاء سعوديين ريانا
برناوي وعلي القرني والتي ستكون في الربع
الثاني من العام الحالي ثم مهمه فضائيه
الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه اي اس اس ومدتها
عشره ايام وسيتم خلال المهمه اجراء 14
تجربه بحثيه علميه سته منها في الدماغ
واربعه منها في الخلايا البشريه وواحده
منا في الاستمطار وثلاثه تجارب تعليميه
توعويه في الجاذبيه الصغرى خلال المهمه
سيتم معرفه مدى التكيف البشري في رحلات
الفضاء وفهم تاثيرات التواجد في الفضاء
على صحه الانسان وتحديد ما اذا كانت رحلات
الفضاء امنه على الدماغ البشري وتهدف
الهيئه الى اشراق الطلاب في التجارب
العلميه اذ من التواصل مع رواد الفضاء
السعوديين مباشره باجراء تجاربهم معا
وقالت الهيئه ان نتائج هذه التجارب ستعزز
مكانه المملكه عالميا في مجال استكشاف
الفضاء وخدمه البشريه لتعزيز الشركات
الدوليه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تسعه طويله هي عصابات في
السودان سببت حاله من الترويع والتوجس هي
عصابات متخصصه بالنهب والسرقه بالاكراه
يظهرون على الدراجات الناريه ولديهم طريقه
معينه بالنهب والهروب بسرعه البرق وحالات
السرقه بواسطه العصابه المذكوره وحراميه
اخرين تشهد ارتفاعا في مدن السودان
المختلفه مؤخرا شرطه ولايه الجزيره في
محاوله للتعامل مع الظاهره والحد من حالات
السرقه قررت اتباع اسلوب جديد واعلنت عنه
في منشور على حسابها على فيسبوك وفي
المنشور كما ترون اعلنت الشرطه ان هذه
الرساله لكل من تسول نفسه العبث بممتلكات
المواطنين وانها ستقبض على هؤلاء وتصورهم
لايف ليراهم العالم ويتعرفون عليهم الشرطه
يبدو انها استبقت وتوقعت معارضه البعض
للقرار تبررت وقالت ردا على كل من يعتبر
هذا تشي وانتهاكا لحقوق الشخصيه ان السرقه
وترويع المواطنين اكبر مهدد وفيه انتهاك
لحقوق ايضا وبالفعل بدات فورا بعضها
بتطبيق القرار ونشرت فيديو اعترافات مع
شخص اسمته اخطر معتدي سرقات النشد
جنب الحفلات ولا معاك ناس بيشتغلوا
انت قاعد
مئات السودانيين دخلوا فورا على منشور
الشرطه على فيسبوك وعلقوا مرحبين ومؤيدين
للقرار الذي راوه راضيا لللصوص وعصابات
تسعه طويله وحتى البعض تمنى لو قرارا كهذا
اتخذ من زمن بعيد
كما شاهدتم الغالبيه العظمى من المعلق
المؤيدين للقرار ومرحبين به وطمحي لان
يكون رادعالصوص والنشالين لكن ايضا على
اصوات المعارضه للقرار وترفيه تشهيدا وانه
قد يفاقم الازمه ولا يحلها والبعض تساءلوا
ان كان الامر قانونيا اصلا
وللحديث اكثر عن الموضوع معنى من الخرطوم
المحامي اياد قاسم خالد اهلا بك استاذ
اياد انت محامي ومدافع عن حقوق الانسان شو
رايك بهذا القرار للشرطه
اهلا بك مساء الخير واهلا بضيوفك الكرام
وجميع المشاهدين
ابتداء لايصال المعلومه كامله في ظل
القانون السوداني او قانون الاجراءات
الجنائيه السوداني لسنه 1991 وهو القانون
المختص بالاجراءات التي تتخذها النيابه
عبر الادوات التنفيذيه وهي الشرطه
للبحث واستقصاء البينات والتحريات
تمر الدعوه الجنائيه في القانون السوداني
بمرحلتين مرحله التحقيقات ومرحله المحاكمه
نتحدث الان عن مرحله التحقيقات او مرحله
البريترايل
والتي يكون فيها للنيابه سلطات واسعه حول
الضبط والتفتيش والقط
لكن بالحديث عن هذه المرحله انا ارى ان
هذا
الحدث او حتى هذه الظاهره ظاهره التسعه
طويله مع كامل التضامن مع كل ضحاياها وكل
من وقع ضحيه لهذه الجريمه الا انه لا يمكن
ان نصل بالاجراء
متطرفين الى حد تصوير المتهمين وعرضهم
امام الاعلام وامام المجتمع ونحن في هذه
المرحله من التحريات حيث ان داخل القانون
الاجرائي السوداني في الماده الرابعه منه
في الفقره جيم تنص على مبدا اصيل وهو
براءه المتهم حتى تثبت ادانته والحق في
المحاكمه العادله والناجزه يتفق هذا
المبدا مع الاتفاقيه الدوليه لحقوق
المدنيه والسياسيه لسنه 1996 والتي نصت
على ذات الله المبدا الاصيل في براءه
المتهم ومن هذا نجد ان هذا الفعل قد يشكل
ايدان اجتماعيه وادانه اعلاميه في مرحله
ما قبل المحاكمه وما قبل اكتمال البينات
التي ترتقي الى توجيه التهمه واحاله
البلاغ الى المحكمه وهي المختصه تحت مبدعه
علنيه الجلسات بالسماح بالتصوير اثناء
المحاكمه وخلافه
الاخر يقول ان تصويرهم ليس مخالفا للقانون
انه يدعم تحقيق العداله حتى ان بعض
القانونيين اتفقوا على هذا الراي ما رايت
انا ارى ان تصويرهم في هذه المرحله من
التحريات ومرحله ما قبل المحاكمه هو اجراء
متاسف ومتطرف تجاه متهم او مشتبه به لم
تكتمل البيانات في مواجهته ولم يحصل على
ادانه امام قاضي طبيعي امام محكمه طبيعيه
بحسب سير الله الامور وبحسب الحق في
المحاكمه العادله حيث انه قد يتم اطلاق
سراحه لعدم اكتمال البيانات او قد يتم
احالته الى المحكمه وتبريئاته عبر المحكمه
بينما نكون قد سبق السيف العزم وتم ادانته
عبر الاعلام وعبر المجتمع بعد كل انها قد
يخفف من حالات النشر
والاعتداءات التي تحصل في السودان كيف
تفسر هذا الاجماع شبه الاجماع على ضروره
يعني كشف هؤلاء اللصوص امام العامه
انا ايضا اسكن السودان واعيش في الخرطوم
وواجهت مثل هذه الحوادث واتفهم السخط
الاجتماعي وحاله الغضب تجاه تمدد هذه
الظاهره الا ان المعالجه لهذه الظاهره لا
يمكن ان تكون بالتعسف والتطرف في استخدام
القانون وقد يرقى الى مخالفته حيث ان
الماده 43 من ذات قانون الاجراءات
الجنائيه ينص على حظر التاثير على التحريم
واي من اطراف التحرير التي يكون بالتاكيد
طرفا منها هو المتهم وهذا التاثير قد يكون
بالاغراء او بالاكراه
حيث ان هذا المتهم قد يقر بالله بالتهمه
فقط
مجرحا حتى لا يتم تصويره او نشره على
الملا
كيف يمكن حل هذه الظاهره التي الصوديوم
بشكل عام
انا في كامل الثقه ان مؤسسه الشرطه
السودانيه هي اكثر من قادره او مختلف في
ادارات المباحث وادارات التحقيقات
الجنائيه للوصول للمعلومات التي قد تمكن
من كسر هذه الشبكات الاجراميه ايضا اثق في
القضاء السوداني الذي سياخذ هذه الظاهره
على محمل الجد وعلى خطرها على المجتمع وقد
يصل فيها الى احكام
ممكن فلنقل العقوبه القصوى من اجل الردع
وهي العقوبه العقوبه في القانون السوداني
فلسفه وقانونا هي من اجل الردع وليست من
اجل التشفي او الانتقام من المتهم او
المدان حتى
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
تناولنا في حلقتنا مبارحه خبر عن اللاعب
البرازيلي داني المتهم بقضيه اغتصاب
وموجود في السجن منذ عشرين يناير بانتظار
محاكمته تطورات قضياته في الامس كانت عن
حالته النفسيه صعبه في السجن وعصبيته
وتوتره ودخوله اضرابا عن الطعام ورفضه
الجلوس مع اي احد من السجناء والسبب بحسب
الاخبار المتداوله هو ان زوجته جوانا
زادته واخبرته بنيتها الانفصال عنه بشكل
نهائي لكن اخبار اليوم متناقضه تماما مع
الاخبار السابقه فصحيفه سبورت الاسبانيه
كتبت ان داني الفيج بدا يعتاد على حياه
السجن وانشا دوري كره قدم بين النزلاء
وقالت الصحيفه بان طلب النزلاء على شراء
الملابس الرياضيه قد تضاعف اربع مرات منذ
دخول الفيجا السجن والسبب مباريات كره
القدم التي يقيمها الصحيفه نقلت عن محاميه
الفيش تاكيدات ان موكلها بحاله مزاجيه
جيده ومتاقلم مع الاوضاع داخل السجن
وعلاقته طيبه بزملائه النزلاء في الداخل
وانهم حتى يطالبونهم بتوقع كثيرا وقالت
ايضا انه واثق من برئته
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا وصلنا الى ختام حلقتنا لليوم
موعدنا يتجدد غدا الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]